you know it's funny uh we had a fun sort
of Adventure where you revealed at one
point that you as a child had always
wanted an American Girl doll and you'd
never got one and I became obsessed with
we have to get you an American Girl doll
yeah remember how this unfolded yes we
were on uh we were not on a bus what am
I saying we were in a van
what is a bus anyway I keep hearing
about this bus is it like a limo but
lung oh no it's a big piece of oh for
public transportation why would you want
to be with other people from the public
I'm so confused we were on a private bus
that Conan did on made of gold made of
gold obviously we were on the way to the
hotel in Chicago I believe
and I don't know why I got on this kick
but I just started talking about oh the
American Girl doll store I think they
had one there and I was like man I
always wanted one but they were so
expensive and my parents never got me
one but that was like the dream and I
would just look at the catalog like it
was a magazine or something you just go
if I had one of those dolls I'd put them
in these shoes and it's why I have such
a great imagination now and the next day
I got a text from somebody who was like
hey uh Conan wants to do a video with an
American Girl doll do you do you want to
come down and do that at like noon and I
was like yeah you're obsessed with
American Girl dolls you never got one I
never got one no okay well
I like to make people's dreams come true
and that's the biggest falsehood I've
ever stated that's not the case and then
you made me choose between kit and
Samantha yes I wanted it to be have an
element of Cruelty to it because it's me
so there were two really needy looking
American Girl dolls but you know please
me
and then I think I said the other one
was going to be murdered yeah you were
like we will be uh melting the other one
into a doll pancake and uh we're gonna
send you the video yeah right you you
did this you did this but I think at the
end you actually gave the other one to
flula I did so which one did you pick I
picked Samantha because I had more
experience with her as a child I had
watched the movies and read all the
books and kit I wasn't as familiar with
so I felt that I didn't feel like I
should pick her right and then in
hindsight I wish I had because kids
cooler you know it was nice is so you
pick your doll and then you were
legitimately very happy to have this
doll and I didn't want to destroy the
other one that would be the act of a
sociopath so I gave it to flula and
flula ended up talk about a guy who
commits to something he ended up holding
it the entire tour now fullerborg you've
seen him in movies pitch perfect perfect
Suicide Squad yeah Suicide Squad and
he's a very funny talented guy Ai and I
love him to death and he's I've done
I've shot a bunch of things with him
um but he uh he's this big good-looking
German guy who like works out all the
time and he was holding his American
Girl doll the entire trip and even we
would go to get dinner at night he would
bring it and he would set it up in a
little high chair and I kept thinking
like this is really funny but when is
this gonna stop yeah and he wouldn't
stop and I think he's still somewhere
right now in Bavaria holding it
I know I felt bad after that I was like
I don't even think he read those books
and he's far more committed to this bit
than I am yeah I was like leave it in
the box and FedEx it to my house I don't
want anything to happen to it on the
plane
kid kittridge she's like oh I grew up in
Depression era Cincinnati and it was
nothing as bad as this